Show me the girl
What is if she is the one who will break this spell?
You must charm her
Be gentle
Kind
Sweet
Come, come, show me the smile
Oh dear...
Woah
The master's not as terrible as he appears
I never thanked you for saving my life
I never thanked you for not leaving me to be eaten by wolves
Papa?
Belle you must leave here. This castle... is... alive.
Who's there?
Do you wish to take your fathers place?
Come into the light.
Show me the girl
Look at her, what if she is the one?
The one who will break this spell
'Allo!
You can talk?
Well of course he can talk!
Hello! Pleased to meet you!
The master's not as terrible as he appears.
I SAY WE KILL THE BEAST!
Think of the one thing you've always wanted.
Now find it in your mind's eye.
And feel it in your heart.
No!
Don't be afraid.
I'm not afraid.